huh you know when I was a little girl I
used to look in the mirror and hold up a
hairbrush you know I'd like to thank the
Academy so here I am and I really would
like to thank the Academy and the whole
Academy staff for this tremendous honor
and for this incredible week
I am so humbled to be here and to be
recognized among such talented and
accomplished peers whom I'm sure will be
lifelong colleagues and friends I want
to thank my amazing team Jen Finneran
who's joining me tonight and brought
such grace and elegance to this film
Dustin Brella Ilan Isakov Marc and
Amanda and all the crew who gave to this
production I want to especially thank my
phenomenal although elusive producer ace
Weems and my partners on the ground and
two dearest friends whom without this
film could not have happened Immanuel
happy mana my wonderful wonderful
translator who has the greatest heart
and was himself a victim of the genocide
and went on this journey with me and
Jessie while my brilliant Coast
cinematographer and a voice of reason
and patience thank you too for teaching
me the meaning of compassion and love
Angie for introducing me to documentary
Brown University who allowed me to
explore my diverse passion with a
wonderful community behind me my
professors at Brown Keith Brown Eric and
John Terry Stephen Kinzer and Rose
McDermott thank you for helping me
construct a balanced lens through which
to view the world and always pushing me
to strive for nuance and complexity to
the incredible couples whose stories
made up this film
Beatrice prudency John Murray DDoS and
Sandrine thank you for showing me what
resilience and tenacity look like and
for courageously showing your stories
your capacity for love amidst atrocity
is astounding to my Rwandan family mama
Papa Asim Biman Z and Golda thank you
for nurturing me and of course to my
extraordinary parents Susan and David
and my brilliant big sister Caroline who
have always been my best friends and my
greatest supporters I love you eternally
and cannot begin to find the words to
express my gratitude for the endless
support you've given me my sister who
taught me how to fight no really like
physically fight she teased me and I'd
beat her up but you know now she she's
been fighting for me ever since my mom
my soul mate who has ferociously loved
me no matter how many times I went to
Zanna went to Africa and forced her to
take a whole lot of next asleep at night
I apologized and my dad who used to
point to the screen and he would say you
see that little M that'll be you one day
he didn't show me how to live he lived
and let me watch I'd like to leave you
with something that I learned after
hearing my host mother's testimony in
Rwanda the greatest courage is not to
fight battles or face enormous
adversities the greatest courage is
losing everything worth living for and
deciding to live thank you so much